[Music]
Justin Timberlake is just days away from
his first solo Super Bowl halftime show
and Kevin Frazier's in Minneapolis at
the Mall of America with justice okay is
he ready Nancy he's calm cool and
collected a lot like Patriots
quarterback Tom Brady who recently
revealed that JT is his man crush today
we got a reaction from Justin that I
made the list who's my man crush that
tough questions Justin Timberlake I like
Justin a lot I love Justin that stays on
my list the feeling is reciprocated if
you want to make this official but I
don't know if the verdict is out on his
dance moves so he has great hair though
clearly these two can't stop the feeling
of a Super Bowl bromance brewing
but during today's press conference in
Minnesota Justin said Jimmy Fallon who
will pre-tape an introduction Sunday
will always be his number one I'm
telling the truth when I said nothing
could ever come between Jimmy and I but
for any fans still hoping for Justin to
get in sync with his boy band pass the
Pepsi halftime performer squashed any
hope of an on-stage reunion no no to be
honest I had a ton of grand ideas about
special guests
you know from NSYNC to Jay to Janet but
this year I'm just excited my band is
the Tennessee kids that I feel like
they're my special guest Justin is
exhibiting zero signs of nerves
considering he has just two full days
left before conquering the stage his
nearly three-year-old Silas was on hand
for his first dress rehearsal inside US
Bank Stadium I was shocked at how
quickly he could cover a hundred yards
at midnight his new album man of the
woods drops Justin gave fans a taste of
a new song called higher higher on
Instagram
[Music]
you